- [Man] Everyone had
to learn how to fight.
Everyone had to get in shape.
It seems unfair, because
Will, you played Ali.
It feels like you started, and
you took that so seriously,
- [Will] Yeah, I did.
- [Man] You really learned to
- [Man] fight like Ali.
You had a head start.
- [Will] Yeah, nah, you know.
I thought I had a head start,
and then I got on the set with this,
this group of people,
and I'm 47 this year,
and the average here is probably 12.
(laughing)
You know, so, I'm
messing around with Joel,
and it's like everybody's looking,
Adewale's looking all strong,
and I was like, you know,
I gotta take my position.
- [Man] Right.
- [Will] Two weeks in, I tore my calf.
- [Man] Oh really?
- [Will] I was like ah,
(mimics yelping dog), ah!
(audience laughs)
You know the sound you make with,
the sound a dog makes
when you step on his foot?
- [Man] Yeah.
- [Will] Yeah, I made
that (mimics dog barking).
(laughter)
- [Man] And Adewale, is that right?
You were sparring with,
a lot of these guys were
sparring with each other.
You were sparring with the ladies, right?
- [Adewale] Don't ask me why, Conan,
but they put me with the ladies.
And I fought Karen Fukuhara,
but believe me, Kick-ahara,
(laughing)
and I fought Cara Delevingne
who can
(crowd cheers)
- [Woman] That's right, that's right.
- [Adewale] And let me tell you,
Cara will Delevingne you, man.
(laughter)